clearly my personality is enough to
carry an entire video and I don't need
any props hi my name is Bruce all been
out those 99 life is different now
it is 419 which is the day before 4:20
which is international marijuana day did
you know that doing grass-eating
marijuana but in some reefer there's a
lot of different ways to describe the
holiday it's the stoner Saturnalia so I
want to show you some food that you
could potentially make for yourself and
others to celebrate the holiday when I
try to cook I mostly end up making
stoner food so I'm gonna lean into the
head and make some deliberate stoner
food to celebrate 4/20 I started
thinking about the holiday I started
thinking about what kind of cravings
stoners might have and what kind of food
I haven't made yet on this channel and I
immediately came to the conclusion
chicken ha ha pot otherwise known as
weed raspy for marijuana rich man's
oregano so I'm gonna make some mini
chicken pot pies but that's not all I'm
also going to duff the pot pies with
other stone door delights I thought one
this is gonna be delicious as and two
this can be a really fun game for people
that are high as [ __ ] all of the pot
pies are going to be covered so you
don't know what filling is in what pie
so when you're super out of your brain
you can just pick a pie and see what
happens everyone that is currently hi
watching this video just went we're
gonna make some mini chicken pot pies
and then we're gonna make some extra
miscellaneous pot pie that I'm calling
kitchen pasta pies I looked up a recipe
on Pinterest for mini chicken pot pies
so we're gonna start with that and then
we're gonna just completely derail cuz
that's what our strong suit is our
strong suit is chainmail so heavy we
have preheated our oven to 375 degrees
yeah I'm looking at Pillsbury pospone
for a recipe for chicken pot pies and
there must be super he's just chicken
frozen mixed vegetables precooked and
some condensed
chicken signals put that on a bowl
that's what you said on 4/20 I'm coolin
hit by some frozen mixed vegetables we
steamed them in her microwave now that
go in that bowl I mean a can of
condensed cream of chicken soup
otherwise known as diary and a can for
me and this goes in wow that looks
exactly like how it's gonna come out and
now is why we put the chicken in but I
couldn't find just grilled chicken and
then I found something that I thought
would be even more relevant to a STONER
meal chicken nuggets I'm gonna chop up
these chicken nuggets and put them in
our mixer fake meat chicken nuggets
because I started out with the idea of
making a vegan chicken pop high and then
it just derailed immediately fake
chicken is so weird chicken goes in we
mix this swap up that's for the ASMR fam
out there I'm gonna take a cupcake or
muffin tin and we're gonna start
building our chicken pot pies make the
crust our chicken pot pies we're gonna
use some biscuits in a two but some
crescent rolls in a tube it says use
biscuits but I got crescent rolls too
we're just gonna get I'm not gonna have
sex with these we're just gonna fly by
the seat of our pants not take my pants
off we got to grease this muffin tin and
we use our biscuits I want to pop oh you
pop Oh God is everything my life so
difficult
Oh Ladas happened I take our biscuit do
this with it stretch it out and put it
in our muffin tin so that it comes up
over the top of the tin oh I'm seeing
this up there we go it goes on the side
sort of this is difficult
oh no we're gonna roll them out oh look
how good this is looking on your fly my
Creator this is not gonna work very well
Deena great oh my god I see the
croissants work better we're gonna make
some biscuits because if these don't
cover up we're gonna put these biscuits
on top like little hats top please
yeah so underwhelming I went to the
penis Museum in Iceland and everything
so phallic take a couple triangles of
these croissants women in the wall B
this is working
basically exactly the same way wow this
looks gummy and pretty terrible we just
pinch these together and put them in
Maui Zowie
does that make quite the difference some
of the fixings need to go in the chicken
pot pies to cook in the oven and some of
them I'm going to put in afterwards
because I don't want them to get too
heated up first things first let's put
in some chicken pot pie mix oh look at
that you can put whatever you want in
your kitchen pots so pop them let's put
some of our other ingredients in what a
summaries like I don't know but I
thought they might like confor cheese
ravioli is this precooked dear God me
precooked okay I gotta cook this on my
own time here's what else we got what do
stoners like I don't know but maybe
cocktail weenies yeah that have some
cocktail weenies cocktail weenies into a
chicken potpie
what do stoners like I have no idea but
maybe some Mexican food this is
basically fake meat with black beans but
I thought maybe you might want to make
one with like taco mix and taco
seasoning so we're gonna try one like
that oh my god we're gonna do two with
some taco season there were through some
taco blended cheese over a little
buddies hey buddies now we're gonna kind
of try and fold over our tops of pies is
a little bit but not worry too much
because we're gonna worst-case scenario
just put the biscuits on top in this one
you know what I was gonna do I'm just
gonna put some chicken nuggets then the
chicken pot pie recipe says you put this
in the oven for about 30 minutes so
let's do it and see what happens we're
also just gonna put our biscuits in to
cook like the package direction say whew
alright well be right back in 30 minutes
everything's covered in grease we're
back I'm pretty sure things are burning
so we're gonna get them out of the oven
now let's do it like wow how to assess
these I think it's the same as assessing
my youtube channel some are good and
some are very bad we're gonna cool down
for a second before we really get into
figuring
with the to do with these also buildings
been cooking so let's finish that I've
been traveling a lot I can really use a
facial right now does that read on
camera not me
I don't I never read on camera got a
raviolis I'm gonna add something ragu
sauce I don't know not spawns oh who
cares I mean I love ragu anyone out
there got a weird steam fetish you steam
fam I'm gonna let these cool down for a
little bit and get right back to you
many things I've had a second to chill
and also our food is that a temperature
in which we can handle it with our hands
like I said some of these are great some
of these need some work so far we had
some great ones happening right here oh
my god you can see our tiny wieners
actual chicken pot pie and then our
mystery ones these ones actually work
these were made with the croissant here
was my thoughts on the other one some of
the feelings I wanted to keep cold so
I'm just using my fingers to manhandle
it and hollow it out in the middle this
crust and I have a lot in common we're
both very flaky
what does turner's like I have no idea
that maybe home with some pita chips
I'll take a spoonful of hummus over
there right in the center that kitchen
pots the pies I'm gonna take my pita
chips I would take a couple of them and
just crunch them up right on top
Oh a variety of carbs all in one
conveniently handheld meal yes please
then for our other hollowed-out biscuit
what a stoners like I don't know but
maybe happy Olli with sauce this one
might not be the best but we're gonna
try to smash these raviolis right inside
there and I want some shredded
mozzarella cheese that i'ma throw on top
of this ravioli here's the fun thing
about this meal worst-case scenario you
just made a ton of food you can just eat
without it being inside a biscuit so
maybe that was the better way to go with
this video but now I decided to make it
extra complicated and so because we
wanted to be a supply we're gonna take
our biscuits and these are a little
thick so I'm gonna cut them in half this
is very good again it for the ones that
are a little too expose we're gonna take
our biscuit tops and just cover them
right up no one knows what's in there oh
my god and you can do that with any
variety of fillings that you want this
is an extraordinarily complicated way to
just get stoner food into your body so I
doubt any of you will do this on 4/20
but I hope maybe some of you do if you
have a significant other of someone that
really loves to celebrate 4/20 then this
might be a really nice fun meal for you
both to enjoy Oh extra note I bought
some flamin hot cheetos because if you
want you can go the extra mile crush up
some flamin hot cheetos as just like a
nice little like sprinkles on top of
some of your supplies it well there you
go there are my kitchen pot surprises I
hope you guys make them in honor of 4/20
or just any day I just hope you guys
watch this video to be very honest and
even like these cooking videos give this
video a thumbs up so I know that I
should be making more of these and
subscribe to this youtube channel and
make videos Monday Wednesday and Friday
sometimes I don't know in cooking
tradition we should probably taste one
of these vs. taste the chicken pot pie
oh my god oh my god that's so good why
did I spend so much money on all the
other food I'm gonna try this surprised
- I don't even know what this is oh I
just straight up chicken nugget isn't
making me tired guys this is all assume
that the rest of them tasting delicious
and subscribe to my youtube channel just
move on with our lives in which we
anticipate ever genius video that I
might make Monday Wednesdays and Fridays
from here until infinity forever a my hi
their recipe set
I thought I was thirsty but my dog is
thirsty